to participate in this this is the first
security council meeting
since developments in libya that the un
say may be a breakthrough
a fragile ceasefire is now in place and
at talks in tunis we've seen the
beginnings of a peace deal
that's supposed to lead to elections in
about a year's time
i am optimistic about the way forward in
libya
yet clear-eyed about the many challenges
that lie ahead
ten years of war cannot be solved one
week of political talks
but we hear more now the language of
peace
rather than the language of war for the
sake of libya
75 odd libyans came together in tunis
last week
in a good faith effort to start the
process
of healing their nation's wounds but a
researcher from the well-respected
international crisis
group who's followed developments in
libya during its last decade of conflict
says the very many challenges ahead
should not be underestimated
i'm heartened by the fact that now we're
not seeing open conflict in libya but
i'm not entirely optimistic that we've
seen the end of this
devastating uh destruction or
self-destruction of the country by
by the hands of uh of the libyans
themselves
uh it's uh it's too early to say that
whether the country will come out of
this
enormous economic recession that it has
suffered
whether they'll be able to go beyond the
ideological divides that's still cut
through
the country the problems are among the
libyans
there's been no agreement on a new prime
minister or a unified
presidency council as proposed by the un
the country remains divided the prime
minister in tripoli fires al-saraj
has indicated he's prepared to stand
down in benghazi
general khalifa hafta has made no such
pledge
and there's the big issue of foreign
involvement under the ceasefire deal
all non-libyan forces are supposed to
leave the country by early next year
few are hopeful that will be achieved
under the deal that's been done the un
is supposed to provide
monitors to be deployed in libya to
observe the ceasefire that will need
a un security council agreement
negotiations are likely to be difficult
one member of the council a permanent
member russia
has nationals in libya working for
wagner
what many consider a mercenary company
that's been fighting on the side of
general hafta
james bayes al jazeera at the united
nations